- I feel like I'm going to get stumped.
- Yeah, Trump stumped. It's
like the bad version of
a tramp stamp, a Trump stump.
- Ew!
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- I mean, that has to be Democrat.
- I feel like all of those
words are too big for Trump.
- It's too long-winded to be Trump.
It's got to be Democrat.
- I know it was Bernie
Sanders that said it.
- I'm going to go with Trump.
- Considering his ideology,
I have to go Democrat.
(bell dinging)
- (gasps)
- Damn!
- What, so he's over there thinking now?
- Oh, he's pandering.
- He's a flip flopper.
He doesn't mean this.
(upbeat music)
- That is true.
- It's just really absolutist.
Obi-Wan says that only
Siths deal in absolutes.
- A Sith lord.
- I'm going to have to
also say it's Bern-Man.
- I'm going to go with my gut.
- I'm going to disagree. I'm
going to say that it's this.
(bell dinging)
- Oh!
- Womp.
- We're all getting As on this test.
(upbeat music)
- I want to say this again,
but I'm worried I'm going to be wrong.
- Does Donald Trump even know women exist?
- I feel like that's not a Hillary,
because she's not using like "we."
- Hillary, Hillary.
- You don't know, just say Trump.
(bell chiming)
- Ha!
- Ugh. Love her, girl.
- Trump doesn't want
women to have anything.
- He doesn't like being
interviewed by them,
he doesn't like periods.
(upbeat music)
- The syntax of that sentence
sounds very Trump-esque.
- It does.
- He's used to, "You're
fired. You're deported."
- This is so hard.
- This is a lot harder than
I thought it was going to be.
- One hundred percent Hillary.
- I think it's Hillary.
- It's really damning if he said it,
so I'm going to say Democrat.
- I'm going to say Trump
because I'm confused now.
- I'm going to go -
- Trump.
(bell dinging)
- What?
- Ugh!
- He likes me? He likes my people?
- Not anymore, though.
(upbeat music)
- I feel like Trump wouldn't
think that critically
about the different people in society.
I think he just makes
grandiose statements.
- Terrorist is a fear-mongering word.
- It's not a Bernie word.
- Democrat, still?
- I'm going to say this because
I feel like it's still a trick.
- I'm going to have to say Trump.
- Donald Trump.
(bell dinging)
- Dammit!
- Dammit.
- If he said that, I'm impressed,
because where has that been?
- That's definitely not Trump.
- That, to me, has got
to be Hillary Clinton.
- Okay, fine.
(bell dinging)
- What?
- I feel like a lot of
Trump supporters today
would not get behind a lot of
the statements that were his.
- Politics is just a game.
Donald Trump is just like,
"You know what, now I'm
going to play this game,
too, like you guys."
- I feel like we're fighting against
the Trump of today,
which is the ridiculous,
punch-everyone-in-the-face Trump,
and the Trump of yesterday.
They're two completely different people.
- That's true.
- It's Jeckyll and Hyde.
(upbeat music)